okay
we've uh in 2020 and still living
through a pandemic
setting the the the the political and
all those kinds of things aside
i've always found viruses fascinating
as as living as dynamical systems i was
going to say living systems but
i've always kind of thought of them as
living you know but
that's a whole other kind of discussion
maybe it'd be great to put that on the
table
one do you find viruses beautiful slash
terrifying and two do you think they're
living
things or there's some aspect to them
for our discussion of life that makes
them living
i mean living in a pandemic saying
viruses are beautiful is probably a hard
thing but i do
find them beautiful to a degree i think
even even even in the sense of mediating
a global
pandemic there's something like deeply
intriguing there because
you know these these are tiny tiny
little things
right and yet they can um uh
you know essentially um like cause a
seizure or like you know handicap an
entire civilization at a global scale so
just that intersection
between you know our perceived
invincibility and
our susceptibility to things and and
also the interaction across scales of
those things is just
a really amazing feature of our world
most technology whether it's viruses or
ai
that can scale scale in an exponential
way like
right kind of run you know like
as opposed to like one thing makes
another thing
makes another thing it's one thing makes
two things and those two things make
four things and then
like that kind of process
also seems to be fundamental to life yes
and uh it's terrifying because in
in a matter of in a very short time
scale
it can uh if it's good at being life
whatever that is yeah it can quickly
overtake the
the other competing forms of life right
and that's scary both for ai
and for viruses and it seems like
understanding these processes
that are underlying viruses and i don't
mean like on the virology or biology
side
but on some kind of more computational
physics
yeah perspective as we've been talking
about yeah seems to be really important
to
to uh figure out how humans can
survive right along with
these kinds of all this kind of life and
perhaps becoming a multi-planetary
species
is a is a part of that like there's no
maybe like what we'll figure out from a
physics perspective is like there's no
way
any living system can be stable for a
prolonged period of time and survive
unless it expands exponentially
throughout like
we have to multiply otherwise
anything that doesn't multiply
exponentially will die eventually maybe
that's a fundamental law
um maybe i don't know i you know i
always get really bothered by these
darwinian narratives that are like you
know like the fittest replicator wins
and things and i don't i just don't feel
like that's exact
exactly what's going on i think like the
copying of information is sort of
ancillary to this other process of
creativity
right so like the drive is actually the
drive is creativity but if you want to
keep the creativity that's existed in
the past it has to be copied in the
future
right so replication like if you so that
for me is
so i had this set of arguments um with
michael lockman and lee cronin about
the like life being about persistence
they thought it was about persistence
and like survival of fittest kind of
thing and i'm like no it's about
existence it's like
because when you're talking about that
it's easy to say that in retrospect you
can post select on the things that
survived and then
say why they survived but but you can't
do that going forward
that's really profound that survival is
just a nice little
side effect feature of maximizing
creativity but it doesn't need to be
there
yeah i like people yeah yeah like i said
i like optimistic theories
well i don't know if that's up to me
that that could be terrifying to people
because
yeah because uh you know a system that
maximizes creativity may very quickly
get rid of humans for some reason if it
comes up with some
other creative i mean yeah
forms of existence yeah right this is
the ai
thing it's like the moment you have an
ai system that can
that can flourish in the space of ideas
or in some other space
much more effectively than humans and
it's sufficiently integrated into
into the physical space to be able to
modify the environment
i think we'll just be like the core
genetic architecture or something we'll
be like the dna for
ai right it's like we haven't lost the
past informational architectures on this
planet they're still there
yeah also the ai will use our brains in
some part
to like like ride like it'll accelerate
the exchange of ideas that's the neural
link
dream is that well the humans will be
still around
because you're saying architecture yeah
but i don't i don't even think they
necessarily need to tap in our brains i
mean just collectively we do interesting
things what if they were just using like
the patterns in our communication or
something
oh without controlling it just observing
well i i don't know in what sense do you
control the chemistry happening in your
body
hmm yeah i i mean i i
obviously i don't know i'm just i i just
like the way i look at
like people look at ai and then they
look at this thing that's bigger than us
and is coming in the future and is
smarter than us and i think though
that looking at the past history of life
on the planet and what information has
been doing for the last four
billion years is probably very
informative to asking questions about
what's coming next
um and i don't
one is planetary scale transitions are
really important for new phases so the
global internet and sort of global
integration of our technology i think is
an
important thing so that's again life is
a planetary scale phenomena
but we're an integrated component of
that phenomenon i don't really see that
the technology is going to replace us
in that way it's just going to keep
scaffolding and building and
and i also don't have an idea that we're
going to build ai in a box i think ai is
going to emerge
agi to be is a planetary scale phenomena
that's going to emerge from our
technology
planetary scale phenomena but do you
think
an agi is not distinct from humans we're
the whole
package the whole package comes as a
planetary scale phenomenon
and that goes back to the fact that like
you were you know asking questions about
you as an individual
like what are you as an individual
you're like a packet of information that
exists in the particular physical
thing that is you we're all just packets
of information and some of us are
aggregates in certain ways but it's all
just kind of exchanging and propagating
right and
processing
you